tonight UNLV football holding a public
vigil to honor the life of Ryan Keeler
good evening to you thank you for
joining us at 11 I'm Brian Loftus I'm
Denise Valdez in fact you might recall
the 20 year old died very suddenly last
week and earlier tonight the public
gathered at Rebel Park Madison Kimbrough
was there and joins us live from the
Fertitta football complex with more
yes it was an emotional evening as about
a hundred people gathered to honor Ryan
Keeler described as an incredible person
student and athlete
we talk about football we talk about
life we laugh we cry as I think about
Ryan and his life and his legacy that's
what I'm thinking about is is the
memories that we share former UNLV
football player Austin ajake describing
his bond with defensive lineman Ryan
Keeler 20 year old Keeler was found
unresponsive in his apartment last week
this Monday a vigil was held for him on
the practice field at the Fertitta
football complex at Rebel Park he had a
quirky personality he could fit in in
any group
in any group setting and he was just
himself all the time healer was a
sophomore and wore number 47 his fellow
teammates and fellow student athletes
lined up on the 47-yard line in his
honor Brian's work ethic was the best on
the team his grades were the best on the
team I mean everything he did was was
amazing so if we can just Channel Ryan's
energy a little bit use that to be our
Catalyst healer transferred to UNLV from
Rutgers University and was an academic
all Mountain West honoree and while his
family wasn't able to attend the vigil
his teammates shared the impact he's had
on their lives I was really good friends
with him
we would we'd come out here together and
get extra work and we were the same
position you know what I mean and he he
was a huge part of this defense this
year
the cause of Ryan's death is still
unknown but we are told that his family
was here all week from Chicago and just
left today the family asked that
tonight's vigil will be recorded so they
could have it as a Memento to take home
to their family reporting live Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now